hello friends John Perry here welcome to
Sunday morning science today I'm gonna
be going over the machinery of life
which is a book by David Goodsell he is
an artist he is a scientist and he has
done something spectacular here this is
more than a book review I'm actually
gonna go through some of the
illustrations in here and describe
what's going on in them this is no
substitute for actually getting a hold
of this book and reading it for yourself
as you will see now normally I do my
Sunday morning broadcasts live but the
illustrations in this book are too good
and I couldn't bring myself to just show
them through the camera on my computer
so I did do a pre recording with my
nicer camera and if you happen to be
watching this live the moment that it
premieres on Sunday morning I will
actually be in the live comments
responding to people's questions so I am
still here let's dig in alright here we
go the machinery of life by David s
Goodsell now this book is it is probably
the most spectacular book that I have
ever read it's really not I almost even
don't want to call it a book it's a
masterpiece
you know David Goodsell he has
completely changed how we visualize
molecules so this this molecule here
this is ATP synthase and this isn't I
mean the coloration here is his style
but this is what's called a
space-filling atomic model so you can
actually kind of see each individual
atom there's a bunch of atoms here and
it's kind of it's probably hard to see
in the video harder to see than in real
life when you look at this but each atom
is drawn as a sphere and the outline of
that sphere that really shows what the
outline of the electron cloud is of that
atom now atoms are actually they have
fuzzy borders their electron clouds are
actually fuzzy but for the most part
these these little outlines here show us
where if this molecule were to bump into
another molecule it would interact there
that
and it would either bounce off or it
might be attracted to the other molecule
so this is these space-filling models
these are the most accurate models if
you want to see how it is that atoms
would actually interact with each other
so we've got several proteins stuck
together to create this this machine and
this is fairly common style of image and
you'll see this in a lot of textbooks
and so on the really unique thing about
what David does you'll see here in a
second is he does these watercolor
paintings that are absolutely amazing
and they show us really the noise inside
of a cell all the chaos that happens
inside of a cell but even here he's
colored this in a way that it's really
easy to see each different parts so each
of these different colors represents a
separate protein that is involved in
this system so this is a multi-part
protein and we see that when it's put
together in functioning and actually
acts as a rotor a motor this part right
here spins and it's spinning causes
these to move and inside there are
little holes where the precursors to ATP
are attracted and they go in there and
they get smashed together this is the
machine that literally smashes together
molecules to make ATP it's really really
cool how this works and to figure out
how this thing worked took thousands of
hours maybe hundreds of thousands of
hours of people in the lab trying to
figure out first of all what the
structure of each of these proteins is
and how it is that they might work
together as a functional unit to create
these little little molecules of ATP and
so in in the cell this actually sits in
the membrane this part is embedded in
the membrane and this actually faces
inward in towards the the inner part of
the mitochondria that's where ATP is
made so we haven't seen anything really
unique here this is just his coloration
scheme that makes it really nice and
easy to see what we're looking at when
we're looking at these biomolecules so
here we have a bunch of other proteins
that are that are done in the
space-filling manner here we have DNA
here
and DNA polymerase riding on top of that
so that's what DNA looks like if you
were to look at the shape of DNA and
really be able to see it really well
that's what it would look like I think
you should probably point out some
people might be wondering why do we why
don't we model these are 3d models
obviously why do we do 3d renders of
molecules instead of just look at them
underneath the microscope with an
electron microscope a scanning electron
microscope we can see some proteins some
of the extra large proteins we can
actually see them but we can't see them
very clearly and then with a scanning
tunneling microscope we can see
individual atoms but we can only see
atoms and molecules if they are laying
flat on the flat surface these are
complex three-dimensional structures we
cannot see these we have to break them
into pieces to look at pieces if we want
to look at them under a scanning
tunneling microscope and actually see
the individual atoms it's really
difficult to see an actual protein and
not just to see an actual protein but to
see what what it would look like when
it's in solution we do not have tools to
do that and so to get these structures
it takes scientists just people in the
lab slaving away to figure out what
these structures actually look like how
it is that these proteins fold what
their three-dimensional shape is in
solution inside the cell and what
functionality that shape gives that
protein so this is this book it's just
150 pages long but it gives us an
insanely beautiful overview of what
scientists have been working so hard to
figure out and this does better than any
textbook that I have ever seen here's an
image from my microbiology textbook
most of the time they they show things
with diagrams and sometimes it they do
the 3d models like you'll see and and in
the beginning of David good sales book
they have a good cell he's he's been
studying biochemistry he knows these
molecules inside and out and he as we
will see is an amazing artist and we'll
get to his actual contribution here just
just a minute here but this is if we
zoom in this right here in red is a
chain of RNA and
bass filling model forms so each of
these circles each of these is an atom
and you know it's it's roughly it's
showing us the where the electron cloud
of that atom reaches out in a way that
it can actually affect the neighboring
atoms it can either attract them or
bounce off of them depending on you know
with what that neighboring atom happens
to be and here we are seeing kind of
sumed in too close to really see what's
happening but we're looking at two
transfer rnas and so they're actually
chains of RNA as well and these are the
anticodons these are the the parts that
stick to the messenger RNA this is
information transfer inside of a stuff
if you want to see an animation of how
this works a simplified animation of how
this works my video what is DNA and how
does it work it explains this process so
this is transfer RNA coming in at the
heart of the ribosome actually if I
scroll back here a few pages I think do
you believe there's a picture so this is
a cell membrane here these are all the
fatty molecules that make up a cell
membrane and the the heads are attracted
to water and the tails are really oily
so water repels them and so it forms a
membrane around the cell so this is just
a slice of that membrane so you see this
is one of the fatty molecules that's got
two legs in a head the head's attracted
to water the two legs are repelled by it
and water just interacting with these
pushes them together into these big
globs and in in real life if this was
animated you'd see all everything would
be swirling around but I'd be staying in
this structure this big long membrane
and actually it form a a sphere around
the cell and so that's that's cool but I
want to show you a ribosome now here's
the subunit of the ribosome here is
messenger RNA here is DNA and then here
is a transfer RNA transfer RNA what it
does is it brings a single amino acid to
the ribosome as the messenger RNA is
telling the ribosome how to build
protein
so again details on that in the what is
DNA and how does it work
animation over only stated clearly
channel he not only is as art amazing
but just his description of what's
happening is spectacular ok here we go
for a second I thought this was the
ribosome this is not this is RNA
polymerase that's this is what takes DNA
inside the nucleus of the cell and makes
an RNA copy of it RNA polymerase is what
does that inside the nucleus of the cell
here we go this is the ribosome
structure that actually reads messenger
RNA and creates proteins so we got a
protein in green coming out the top here
are the this the purple here is the one
of the units of the ribosome the blue is
the subunit of the ribosome the
messenger RNA it contains the
information to code for a specific
protein is right here it's being read
right now and these are two transfer
RNAs notice that the transfer RNA has on
its tip a an amino acid and the ribosome
takes that amino acid and will fuse it
to the growing chain of protein and
that's how protein is built inside of
the ribosome and the specific sequence
of RNA determines which amino acids will
be added to this growing protein as it
forms and the sequence ends up
determining the function so as the as
this chain comes out it bends and it
folds and it sticks to itself to form a
perfectly shaped three-dimensional
protein that will have whatever function
it has evolved to have over the course
of evolutionary history and that that
process is absolutely spectacular now
sometimes the protein doesn't come out
perfect it has to be guided by other
molecules inside the cell they actually
force it's it's folding as it as it goes
but yes so again these are all pretty
simple space-filling models like you
would see in a typical textbook there's
nothing super new here yet just that the
way that he colors things it's both it's
beautiful and it really helps you see
what it is that you're looking at here
again we have ATP synthase that
we saw earlier and here you see how it's
embedded in the membrane there and it
spins right there it's producing ATP is
what it's doing and this this is what
David Goodsell is famous for this is his
huge and really valuable contribution to
science education is this his ability to
make these types of illustrations so
this is a little chunk of the cell on
the cover so this is a bacterial cell
here and this is a zoomed-in chunk on
one of the here we have the flagella
flagellum one of its flagella sticking
out the side here and this thing spins
like a rotor here we have the ribosome
so this is the thing that that reads RNA
and builds protein and this is the
messenger RNA this little pink strand
here down here we have the DNA of the
bacteria and what what this does is it
just shows you how how messy and how
complex and how beautiful the inner
workings of a cell really are it is just
a jumbled mess chaotic mess that is just
roaring I mean if you were to see this
in animation things would be moving so
fast that you could not see them the
chemistry that's happening here is
absolutely amazing here we have a
molecule that's it's unwinding DNA using
half of that DNA to make an RNA copy
that RNA copy as it's being made is
going through a ribosome which is using
that to build protein here we have this
little pink thing right here this pink
blob that is a transfer RNA it's
bringing amino acids to the ribosome so
that it can build protein and this is so
cool this this art style is so cool it
is so easy to see what's going on here
this green guy right here that is ATP
synthase that is what's upside-down
compare the earlier illustration but
that is this this molecule here so this
entire molecule here he simplifies that
and draws it as this little green blob
here you can still recognize it it's
three-dimensional shape is still the
same it's a outline is still the same
but what what you get to see here and
you'll train yourself pretty quickly
when you're reading this book is to how
to how to really look at this and so how
to make sense of this hey you can spend
hours on each illustration studying
these but he's just showing you how all
of these things interact with each other
and that is so wonderful because if I go
back if I go back here what you know
we're used to seeing these these
different structures on their own you
know as Islands you could say but that's
not how they actually are in real life
in real life they are all interacting
with each other in this really crowded
congested mess up here we have the
sugars sugary molecules that are
sticking out on the surface so so cool
this is so amazing no one has ever done
anything like this no one has ever
accurately shown the chaos and the mess
that exists inside of a cell I say chaos
and I say mess but it's obviously it's
it's working its function it's it's it
reminds me a lot of when you when you go
to like a South America a really busy
city in South America I lived in Sao
Paulo for a while and everything is just
chaotic and Sao Paulo there's the
traffic is crazy things aren't working
the way that they should the lights are
broken there's there's just people
everywhere there's people trying to sell
you stuff it's just a chaotic city
inside of a cell these each of these
molecules has its own evolutionary
history most of which we don't
understand most of the molecules and in
structures inside of a cell we don't
have good understandings of how they
evolved it's actually just recently that
we're starting to figure this out we're
starting starting to do this work up
until now for the most part all we've
been doing in the study of these
molecules is trying to figure out what
their shapes are and what their
functions are just now I mean I would
say the last 15 years we've had
evolutionary biologists take interest in
this and try to start figuring out what
their evolutionary history was it's
really cool I mean you're seeing stuff
here that we barely are starting to
understand this page here is really cool
it shows you
I actually just zoom in more on this
actually okay I've zoomed in all the way
here and I'm holding it sideways so we
can really see these these two images so
this is his his watercolor painting his
painting style and this is what those
would look like if you actually drew
them in space-filling 3d style and so
here we have this protein I believe I
forget the name of it but it's the
protein that it helps metabolize sugars
and next to it these little aqua colored
spots those are water molecules so these
are just you know in real life of the
word hit play on this if this were an
animation those will be moving so fast
that we could not see them everything in
here would be jumbling around and this
just chaotic mess that jumbling is part
of what powers the movement of these
proteins and the function of these
proteins they've evolved in this jumbly
chaotic mess of a world
here we have a a string of RNA and we
see a string of RNA in his illustration
style right there so this gives you a
really good idea of what's going on in
his his illustration so he does not draw
the water he ignores water and he
actually ignores pretty much all small
molecules he only draws the
macromolecules so the DNA and the
proteins and the some of the sugar
chains
so that's bacteria and he he has these
amazing little illustrations here where
everything is labeled and he has
descriptions of everything he's writing
he's telling us about all the different
molecules that are involved here he's
telling us what their functions are
super super cool here here we got the
genome oh my gosh there's so much so
many cool things happening in the genome
all these different molecules that run
on top of the DNA and check it for
breaks they check it for the unwind it
and make up chains of RNA there's
molecules that bind a single-stranded
DNA there's a it's so so cool what's
going on in the nucleus of a bacteria
and again each of these molecules have
their own evolutionary history complex
evolutionary history some of them are
working together as a system some of
them are not working the other as a
system at all they're just independent
origins
you'll find them in some species not in
other species some of them are universal
the ribosome is universal all organisms
today except for viruses have ribosomes
and actually it's one of the reasons
that some people don't consider viruses
to be alive is they don't have their own
ribosome but yeah it's just it's cool
it's so cool I have spent hours hours
looking at these and just it's
captivated my mind I've been dreaming
about molecular machines and you know
the inner workings of the cell here we
have a an actual microscopic image of a
human cell this is a white blood cell
and over here we got a mitochondria in
the cell and he has taken slivers of
this image this is a real image and he
has converted those into his own
painting style so it's such a such a
cool such a cool thing so right now
we're gonna look at this big long one
here this big long painting which he
which spans over several pages here here
we have the nucleus of the cell and here
we have the membrane on the side there
if we if we go back we're seeing this is
the nucleus and that's that's the
membrane there and so here in the
nucleus we have the genome and it's just
you know our human chromosomes are very
complex things are that the DNA is
wrapped around all sorts of different
storage proteins some of the DNA is
locked up so tightly that the cell can
not read it different cell types have
access to different parts of the genome
each human cell has its own full copy of
your genome but only parts of it can be
read in different types of cells and
that that way the white blood cell
creates different proteins and behaves
differently than a cell in your eye you
know or a cell on your skin it's because
different parts of the DNA are bound up
cannot be read different parts are being
exposed so here we have a part of the
DNA that's exposed this beautiful chain
just look at this this is so trippy to
look at this is a fairly accurate
representation of what's happening
inside of your cell right now your cells
trillions of them so here we have the
DNA
here the DNA is being transcribed into
RNA chains of RNA and that RNA is being
transported through this pore here if we
turn the page that RNA is going into the
ribosomes and those ribosomes are
attached to another membrane and they
are building proteins into that membrane
so there actually there's a little
protein there that they're attached to
and they're squirting the new protein as
it as its as the protein chain is being
built they're excreting that into this
little compartment here over here the
one of these compartments by the way
this is a white blood cell so the main
thing that it's making the main protein
that it's making its antibodies so here
we have complete antibodies they're in
their full functional shape here and the
end of the compartment where they were
built is being pinched off by these
molecules these molecules have come in
to pinch off the end and create a little
round vesicle where those are just going
to be pulled around through the cell
after they've been pinched off and so
here's one that's been pinched off you
see it here so that is just a little
sphere inside of the cell and here we've
got all sorts of different proteins and
molecules that are pushing things apart
pulling on things moving them around in
all sorts of different ways and there's
the water in there that's bouncing
everything around there's the ATP which
is being metabolized I guess you could
say it's being broken down to power a
lot of these movements of these proteins
that really need to pull something heavy
the ATP will will attach to a site in
that protein and burst apart and that
bursting will create movement and there
are sometimes just the binding will will
cause a conformation change in the
protein and it will change shape and
cause movement to occur so there's
there's just the normal movement caused
by temperature the normal bouncing
around of molecules inside here that's
that's powering a lot of things inside
of the cell a lot of things are just
passively powered the ambient
temperature inside the cells causing
them and a lot of them are powered by
ATP specifically so again here we these
are
compartments filled with antibodies and
those continue to travel through the
cell these are all different this is
part of the cytoskeleton so this is what
gives the cell kind of a rigid structure
these are motor proteins right here they
actually walk on that bit of
cytoskeleton so they are attached to
this compartment and they are pulling it
they are pulling it towards the membrane
and when these vesicles reach the
membrane they fuse with the membrane the
outer membrane of the cell and they dump
their contents into the blood serum so
again this is a white blood cell it's
making antibodies and it's dumping them
into what you would see as clear liquid
in blood between red blood cells this is
the serum in blood there's a bunch of
stuff in it we normally see it as kind
of this slippery clear liquid but it's
actually full of stuff
so anyway super fascinating and the book
goes on to show a whole bunch of neat
things including here this is I want to
get this huge and like put on that wall
okay so down here we see the hemoglobin
little red structures they're actually
fairly complex therefore part proteins
so remember when we saw the the protein
at the beginning of this video the ATP
synthase and had multiple protein parts
that came together to make to build the
Machine hemoglobin is the same it is
considered a molecular machine with
multiple parts and we now know quite
spectacularly how this evolved this is
one of the few molecular machines where
we really understand it inside and out
and it's evolution so hemoglobin
here we see the cell membrane of the
blood cell and here we have these sugars
that are sticking out the carbohydrates
that determine your blood type actually
so they interact with the world around
them a little bit and if blood cells
that have different sugars than yours
enter your bloodstream your immune
system thinks that they are invaders and
attacks here we see antibodies here at
sometimes the antibodies form these
clusters here and we've got cholesterol
we've got low density cholesterol and
high density cholesterol so different
types of cholesterol and he has them all
labeled and then underneath you know
he's got descriptions of this stuff and
it's this is so cool it's like Where's
Waldo you read about the molecules then
you try and find them and then you see
pictures that are not labeled and you're
trying to find everything that you know
that you've learned about in the book so
far and oh man this book is so awesome
this thing right here labeled see this
is a fibrinogen molecule and this is one
of the main molecules that forms clots
in your blood so it's currently turned
off and an off mode it just kind of
bounces around inside your blood and
it's just just another one of the
slippery little squishy things that's
it's acting sort of like liquid inside
your blood but if it gets activated its
ends become sticky to other versions of
itself and so it'll form connections to
a bunch of it's it's fellow fibrinogen
and actually have a different name and
they get turned on I forget what their
name is they will form a clot they form
giant networks they will catch other
particles platelets and then will form
these giant scabs and stop a wound from
from leaking so that's really cool
oh here on the very next page we see we
see that happening I forgot that was in
here it's called fibrin there we go
it's called fibrin once it's been
activated so you see it's formed these
sticky bonds with all of its neighbors
and what's happened here is that two
cells were ripped apart you know maybe
this person got cut and your cells
sometimes when you get a cut your act
cells will rip but most of them actually
just split apart that's kind of the the
easiest spot for cells to break is
usually between two cells and there are
molecules this protein labeled a here
those little tiny kind of like a little
worm there those molecules are only
expressed between cells at the junctions
and so when when cells get ripped apart
when you're injured
those are exposed and when those are
exposed there are chemicals that that
attached to them and react with them and
it causes a chain reaction that
eventually triggers these fibrin to
become sticky and then they form a clot
so there's actually it's a signaling
system that in this case and in modern
animals mammals is very complex there
are many many steps many different
proteins involved in the blood clotting
cascade and here here we have you
probably recognize this as blood plasma
here you know here's there's a
cholesterol right there there's
antibodies and so on down here we're
seeing you know we got the fibrian's and
so on and this beautiful structure in
the middle here this is an HIV particle
this is a virus so here we have its kind
of little nucleus we've got its membrane
this this virus happens to have a lipid
membrane that it steals from its cell
that it was hatched out of the membrane
inside here is actually made a protein
then we have its RNA genome in the
middle there a bunch of different
proteins here and when it gets into a
cell it releases its genome and the
proteins that are in there and it gives
you aids so this beautiful thing here it
makes people die and this whole chapter
on viruses is great he doesn't have the
current virus in this book because you
know this book is it quite that that new
here we have a beautiful illustration of
a poliovirus here's a cell wall the cell
membrane and it's attached to the
membrane and it's excreting its genome
its RNA genome this is an RNA virus as
it doesn't have DNA it's got our
that goes right into the ribosome of the
cell the ribosome builds proteins one of
the proteins that it makes is a protein
that makes more copies of the virus's
RNA genome and the other proteins are
these packaging proteins that package
the genome back and here we have one
that's almost done packaging the genome
and then you have actual viruses mature
virus viral particles that are right
here that are ready to then pop out of
the cell and go infect a new cell and I
believe that polio just kind of fills up
the cell until it rips apart dies and
ends up ripping apart and that's how
they get out I think they actually kill
the cell other viruses get excreted in
different ways I thought he had the flu
somewhere here here we go look at this
beautiful thing this is a flu virus
budding out from a cell so it actually
buds out of the cell doesn't kill the
cell when it's doing this and the cell
membrane will actually come together you
know touch fuse back together and you'll
have a sphere which is the virus and
then you'll have the rest of the cell
doing its thing again so here we have a
bunch of proteins and the RNA is another
RNA virus the RNA is wrapped around
these proteins so it's genome is nicely
packed inside there and then these are
just proteins on the outside that help
it get into cells help but recognize
cells attach to those cells and then get
inside of them and infect them so yeah
it's a really cool it drives me nuts all
these people saying that viruses are
fake I know this is a painting it's not
an actual photograph of an actual virus
but seriously about hundreds of
thousands of hours of research on
viruses to figure out how all of these
different things work the fact that we
can't see it happen is just because as I
mentioned earlier we have this problem
where we have electron microscopes where
you can see at a certain level
that doesn't give us enough detail to
really see everything and then we have
scanning tunneling microscopy which can
only see flat molecules but we can
actually see individual atoms in
scanning tunneling microscopy but we
don't have a good thing right now a good
tool to look at three-dimensional
structures that are this small in detail
we are working on that the Castle
Research Center and people all over the
place are trying to find better ways to
image macromolecules and you know things
the size of a virus their actual
three-dimensional shape and solution but
right now we do not have a good solution
for this we have to do just insane
experiments insane amount of work to
figure out what these things are doing
what their shapes are we have to look at
their genome with look at protein
folding with all this stuff insane
amounts of work you can do the x-ray
crystallography which gives you what
their structure kind of looks like but
in crystallized form not in solution and
then you have to figure out what it
would be like in solution it's a lot of
very careful science and to just brush
that aside and say oh no viruses are
fake it says all caused by 5g or
whatever there's me nuts
people are so it just read a book look
at this stuff look read the scientific
literature it's so beautiful what people
have been able to figure out and it's
this information was not easily won we
have a wealth of information and it was
hard fought the information is there
just look at it it's there it's online a
lot of it is now public access you can
read these papers for yourselves
anyway you know this this book is tiny
it's a hundred and fifty let's see what
it is exactly what it is 156 pages of
actual you know content a bunch of it's
illustrations but you can't just read
this in a day like you'd rate a normal
page it's a normal book that's 100 pages
long you can spend entire days looking
at one image here and it's the Where's
Waldo
that happens you know trying to find
these different molecules and and you're
reading the key and trying to figure out
what each one is then you read the
description over that how that protein
works because you just forgot you
you just read it and go back and I love
this I love this book the best way to
get David good sales information from
his brain to your brain he has found the
perfect method and it's beautiful just
even if I didn't know what this was I
would just know that it's beautiful
right my review of David good sales book
is uh you know review I don't have any
complaints I liked every bit of it you
know I just I just wish there was more
that's the only thing I wish so I give
him five stars out of five more than
that I like seriously I recommend
everybody get this book read it over
once and then just keep it somewhere on
you on your shelf where you have easy
access to it and come look at these
diagrams again get familiar with the
space-filling models and his
illustration style what it is that he's
doing this is pure genius this book is
amazing